Did you ever become a Muslim yourself?
>> Suleiman. [music]
You know.
Practice a lot, did all of that.
>> long? Up until I was 13. Up until 13,
you're Muslim. Mhm. And then how did you
walk away from it? [music] It was this
this brother Yakub.
You know, very kind. I loved his scent.
I loved his nature.
But apparently he had
>> [music]
>> castrated wino, a homeless person for
urinating on the masjid. At that moment
I started questioning
Islam. We have a clear Hadith, man. Come
on. You can't make this up. It's
happened at the time of the Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him, where a man
entered the mosque. He peed.
And the Sahabah tried to stop him and he
the Prophet said, "Don't stop him. Let
him finish."
I want to invite you to add something
[music] powerful to your Sadaqah Jariyah
list. We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly.
>> Just imagine this. You help someone
learn wudu, how to pray. How to recite
Surah al-Fatiha. Every Fajr, Dhuhr, Asr,
>> Maghrib, Isha, Tahajjud, Tarawih, every
prayer for the rest of their lives, you
share in the rewards. [music] When they
teach their children, and their
children's children,
the reward continues for you.
>> For just £100, you can help teach 20 to
60 people
>> like me learn salah. Donate today and
earn rewards that never stop.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well,
inshallah. So, as you guys know, Patrick
Bet-David, the absolute pet, that's what
he is, the pundit scheme artist, that
Muhammad Hijab calls him, that's what he
is.
You know, this bloody sellout, so he
says he's a Islamophobe, known
Islamophobe, invites Terrence Howard,
who's a known actor, seen him in a
couple of movies. Didn't know, I was
actually shocked to hear this actually.
He interviews him and asks him a
question. But then he asks him that
apparently he was at one moment a Muslim
and he left Islam. From what we know, he
was joining the Nation of Islam, which
are Kuffar. So, I believe he went from
one Kuffar to another Kuffar. But may
Allah guide him to Islam. But here's
what he had to say of why he left Islam
or left Nation of Islam. And the story
is a bit bizarre, a little bit weird.
I'm not saying he's lying, just find it
a little bit strange. Let's watch for
ourselves.
Did you ever become a Muslim yourself?
>> Yes, my name was Suleiman.
You know.
>> [music]
>> Practice a lot, did all of that.
>> long? Up until I was 13. Up until 13,
you're Muslim. Mhm. And then how did you
walk away from it?
I've talked about this before, but there
was
a day I came home and all of the
brothers from masjid was over at the
house [music] and there was this this
brother Yakub.
You know, very kind. I loved his [music]
scent. Loved his nature.
But apparently he had castrated wino, a
homeless person [music] for urinating on
the masjid.
He castrated him? Castrated him. And
>> [music]
>> he's sharing the story with you? He's
telling everybody this?
>> all the brothers around,
>> [music]
>> like 13 of the brothers from the mosque
are there because
Yakub has been arrested and they're
talking about that.
>> [music]
>> And he they were sitting The argument
was he shouldn't have desecrated the
holy temple by urinating on the mosque.
That was what they were talking about.
They weren't talking about the fact
[music] that this young man
or older gentleman was also a child of
God [music]
that may have been lost.
And I was like that
it was so [music] severe. You're
overhearing this conversation?
>> Yes, I'm I'm sitting No, I'm in the
stairs. [music]
And they're in the living room.
>> So, you're not part of the conversation
the 13 men are having. I'm just
listening. Got it. At that moment I
started questioning
Islam. Okay, so there you go. I mean,
the story first he goes that is hearsay
he heard.
I'll be honest with you.
I mean,
I mean let me say now, I heard a
Christian who poked the eyes out of a
baby. I mean, in the in the Bible it
says happy is the one who smashes baby
against the rocks. Not far-fetched. But
again, I'll be a skeptic skeptic here.
But here, talking about something that
is so obvious, which is actually very
bizarre. So, it just shows ignorance.
And I've mentioned this many times
before. No one has harmed me more than
Muslims.
Not the Zionists,
not the far right, not the far left, not
Christians. And no one has harmed me,
I'm telling you, as a Muslim,
as much as Muslims have. No one has
backbitten me, stabbed me, came for my
family members as much as Muslims did.
But I would never come and say, "Hold on
a second, that's Islam." Cuz it's not.
That's not Islam, that's Muslims.
So, for this man to come and say that a
man got castrated because he peed in a
holy mosque or whatever it's called for
that matter. Number one,
what are you on about? If someone comes
and tells you something, I'll fact-check
it. Okay? Like Allah says in the Quran,
if a fasiq and evil one comes to you
with information, verify it. Not only
that, we have a clear Hadith, man. Come
on. You can't make this up. It's
happened at the time of the Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him, where a man
entered the mosque. He peed.
And the Sahabah tried to stop him and he
the Prophet said, "Don't stop him. Let
him finish."
Just look look how it's an absolute
opposite. Look, not him peeing and
getting castrated, the Prophet is seeing
it happen and he goes, "Leave him. Don't
touch him. Don't touch him." Cuz you
know why?
The hikma aspect of what hikma that
stopping him in that instant can harm
him. Or, number two, he can turn around
and, you know, mash up the remainder of
the masjid.
So,
the Prophet waits for him to finish and
goes and educates him. Doesn't say, "I'm
the Prophet of Allah. How dare you? May
Allah curse you, destroy you, castrate
you, finish you." No.
He educates him. Just like the man who
came to the Prophet and said, "Oh,
Messenger of Allah, can you make zina
permissible for me?"
He didn't come and say, "How dare you,
Messenger of Allah? In front of me,
zina."
He said, "Sit down."
And was ready there to take people's
heads off, yeah. But the Prophet said,
"Sit down. Would you want that for your
mother, your sister, your daughter? No,
no, no." Look at the hikma. Not only
that, this is how beautiful Islam is
that it cares about the sinner. I'll
give you another instance.
A companion who used to drink alcohol in
the presence of the Prophet.
They used to whip him, yeah? And
whipping has conditions, by the way. You
can't lift your hand. It's not like
that. The man who's getting whipped has
to wear his day-to-day clothing.
He can't take his No, no, no. What does
this man wear on the day-to-day? He
wears two thick jumpers. He's wearing
two thick jumpers cuz this is symbolic.
When you whip him, you can't do this.
It's from here. That's the condition.
The fiqh There's a condition to it.
And then somebody came and said, "May
Allah curse you."
The Prophet got angry.
He said, "Don't say that, for he loves
Allah and his messenger." He's affirming
iman to the guy who's drinking alcohol.
He's saying, "Don't say that, for he
loves Allah and his messenger." And I'll
give you something profound that will
shock you, bro.
To the core. To the core.
A woman comes to the Prophet and says,
"Oh, Messenger of Allah, I've committed
zina. The I'm pregnant. It's cuz of
zina." Did the Prophet say, "Yes, I
can't wait to stone you." No. The
Prophet moves away from her.
"Oh, Messenger of Allah, I've committed
zina."
The Prophet says, "Just like go away." I
mean, in a nutshell, just go and repent.
She adamantly comes and he's the
Messenger of Allah. He says,
"Give birth to your baby and then come
and talk to me."
Imagine, one year later she gives birth
and she comes, "Oh, Messenger of Allah,
I've given birth.
I I I've committed this. I want to get
the capital punishment."
The Prophet says,
"Go and suckle your baby." Cuz in the
Quran it says it's for two years. "Go
and suckle your baby and then come."
Like he The Prophet is basically saying,
"Listen, just go and repent, man. Go."
She comes back.
Now, at this instance,
they have to enact it. They give the
capital punishment. Some of her blood
Wallahi, I get goosebumps.
Look at the honor Islam gives to a
prostitute. Some of the blood goes onto
the shoe of the Sahabah. You know what
he does? He's like,
like she's dirt.
He says, "Don't do that, for Wallahi,
her blood and her repentance will be
sufficient for Medina."
Medina. Can you imagine? The whole of
Medina, he's saying her sacrifice.
Brother, which man She's more Which man
would come and say, "I want to be
cleansed in this dunya like this than
akhira." Wallahi, it requires guts. And
then to be told, "Go away." And she
comes back. "Go away." And she comes
back. Wallahi, if this is not ihsan,
like when the Angel Gabriel came to the
Prophet and said, "What's ihsan?" He
said, "Worship Allah like you see him.
And if you don't see him, know that he
sees you." Brothers and sisters, this is
Islam. So, when this guy comes and says,
"Castrated this, that, la la la la
story." La la la land, yeah? To us, the
Islam we know and the Islam he knows is
totally different, bro. We don't worship
that lord that Allah that he worships,
with all due respect. So, we ask Allah
to guide this man away from this
absolute rat of PBD, that's what he is.
He's a little flipping pet. He's a rat,
actually. Yes. So, may Allah deal with
him and guide this brother Terrence
What's his name? Not Terrence. Terrence
Howard.
>> Terrence Howard to Islam. Till next
time. As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi
wa barakatuh.
This is the new Sadaqah Jariyah in town.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala tells us in the
Quran a man pleading with Allah to send
him back so he could give Sadaqah. Why
Sadaqah? Because he knows the weight of
Sadaqah. Just £100, you can help teach
20 to 60 people to learn how to perform
[music] salah, recite Surah al-Fatiha,
and make wudu. Click the link and donate
now.